Speaker 1: I'm going to play a clip for
you of Fox News propagandist Laura Ingraham
casually mentioning before a commercial break,
oh, this story about vets being thrown out of
hotels to put in illegals. Turns out the story
was completely false. Don't know why anybody
would make it up. We'll talk to you later. See
you on tomorrow's show. Very casually saying that
entire story. My whole network covered for days.
Turns out it was made up. It happened so quickly,
you might not even notice it. Listen to this.
Speaker 2: All right. Before we go,
a little update on a story we brought
you this week about homeless vets being.
Speaker 1: Displaced from.
Speaker 2: Hotels so that illegals.
Speaker 1: Could move in.
Speaker 2: Turns out the
group behind the claim made it up. We have no
clue as to why anyone would do such a thing,
but we'll bring you any updates should they come.
Speaker 1: That is the this is crazy stuff,
guys. This is really, really crazy. We ran stories
nonstop for a week based on no sourcing on a total
lie. And we got caught. We don't know why anyone
would make this up because they got you to cover
it. Laura, This is the entire point. The the false
naivete. Why would anyone make up a story that
makes Biden look bad and undocumented immigrants
look bad and makes veterans appear to be the
victims of undocumented immigrants? Why would
anyone make that up? Well, it's because this is
what your network traffics in, Laura. Some other
guy also issued this retraction was like Martin.
This one was 30 seconds instead of 20 seconds.
Speaker 3: Quick update on a story from earlier
this week about homeless veterans being displaced
from a hotel in Newburgh, New York. To make room
for migrants, we're now looking into new reports
that a veterans advocate misled lawmakers about or
and media outlets about a story that some homeless
men may have been hired to pose as veterans.
Speaker 1: The equivocation. We're looking
into some claims that may be someone else
lied. And it's possible the entire thing
was a complete hoax meant to fire people up.
Speaker 3: We've reached out to the organization
for a statement, but so far have not heard back.
Speaker 4: We'll send it back to you.
Yes, enough chaos with the potentially
false stories running around out there.
Speaker 1: Yeah. It's too chaotic out there
for false stories to be running around unchecked,
which we do all the time. Which we do all the
time. There's a Daily Beast article that sums
this up. Fox News stoked outrage over migrants
displacing homeless vets. It was a hoax. Fox News
and the rest of right wing media went wild for
a week over a now debunked story about New York
hotels booting homeless vets to accommodate asylum
seekers. This is what they do. And the false
innocence. We can't imagine why. Why would anyone
make this up? Well, why did people make things up
about Hillary and Obama and Biden and Hunter Biden
and whistle blowers that don't exist? This is what
they do to try to convince people to come to their
political side. And this is the equivalent of a
week of page one newspaper headlines and then a
Sunday retraction on page B12. It's it's the
same thing. A week of headlines, headlines,
headlines. The five with a big blockbuster
discussion. Who is really the worst person
involved in this situation where vets are being
kicked out to put undocumented immigrants in?
They don't call them undocumented immigrants, by
the way. And then oh, real quick, before we go,
it's 959 and 40 seconds now before we go. That
story seems someone made it up. We don't know why,
but we'll look into it anyway. And of course, only
a fraction of the audience sees the retraction and
the cycle continues and continues. Laura
Ingram and the entire network should be
ashamed of themselves, particularly in the midst
of hundreds of millions of dollars in lawsuits,
actually billions in lawsuits with nearly
a billion in settlements so far over untrue
things that they have said disgusting. And the
casual nature with with with which they do the
retraction is just like the cherry on top or the
bottom of the barrel or call it what you will.